choose
it what's up fo podcast with Felipe
sparza and Rodrigo Torres yeah man
welcome everybody we're back back couple
of days I got to give you guys right
away man I'm going to be at this weekend
in West Palm Beach Florida at the Improv
August 4 through 7 with Rodrigo Torres
and Adam Murray August 12th Tucson
Arizona at TCC Music Hall August 13th
poblo Colorado at Memorial Hall august
19 and 20 Chicago at Joe's Bar I'm
coming with Marcel aruo and Rodrigo
Torres August 26 through the 28th San
Jose Improv I'll be recording my second
one hour special at the San Jose Improv
August 26 to 28 I'm recording the
special on the 27th two shows so dress
to impress and get there early if you
want to be a part of the live taping sit
in the front audience we're GNA give
away tickets for that show yeah right we
a give a
[__] we can't man we need to um sell
tickets to pay for the special because
um unlike um comedians who got U big who
are big shots they get offered by
Netflix or they get offered HBO special
they get offered Comedy Central specials
me I'm a DIY I'm gonna do it myself I'm
gonna pay for it myself and I'm GNA take
a big risk and I'm gonna try to sell it
to a Netflix or anybody that wants to
buy it after I do it and that's it so if
you want to be part of History be at the
San Jose
Improv August 27 two shows only at the
San Jose Improv of course the next day
I'll have two more shows but there'll be
no more special
recording it'll just be the same jokes
[__] yeah also Rodrigo has a special
shout out right here for Frankie CIO who
was our guest who just got tell him bro
yeah he was a guest on episode 15 on the
cholos where are they now uh series he
just won his civil rights case uh for
his wrongful conviction uh 18year uh
wrongful incarceration he was awarded
$10.1 million and uh he's holding a
press conference uh Thursday August 4th
at 11:00 a.m. along with the murder
victims family family talking about
Justice it's open to the public if
anybody wants to go at lyola Marmont
University life science building
Auditorium room
120 so if you want to be a part of
Frankie coro's history show up there and
show him some love and support let him
know that you heard his story on the
whatsa podcast and it inspired you not
to be bitter about life because that is
one man who is not bitter about life
this guy was thrown into with the wolves
and dead over 20 years in prison and now
he's out with no chip on his shoulder he
doesn't even look like a guy who just
came out of prison after doing 18 or 20
years huh yeah it's his [__] mindset
dude it's all M over matter people
speaking of Mind Over Matter What
happened bro I heard you for what we got
back from Corpus Rodrigo ate the half
half of one of the most strongest
Edibles around and it's strong man I
forgot the name of the edible but we
always buy them at Green wolf in
Glendale shout out to them they cost out
$20 yeah but you're not supposed to eat
half you're supposed to cut it in six
pieces six and I mean six with a capital
siix the first one is strong man Lisa
will tell you my wife she's done with
that [__] and I'm done with eating more
than two when I when I eat one I I pass
out on a play like I needed to calm my
nerves but Rodrigo ate it I couldn't
believe that he ate half and by the time
when you eat half of it it don't just
hit right away it hits here it'll hit
again and then you fall asleep and then
it keeps hitting Rodrigo fell asleep
from the plane in the car in Lisa's car
this fool fell asleep at her house for
an hour and a half slippers was sleeping
on his
back like like those birds that sleep on
top of a alligator he did a bunny hot F
he did a little
Binkies a little Binkies what and then
Rodrigo oh man I don't know how he drove
he drove by the force but the whole time
this fool had a date who makes dates
after a trip like that fool I didn't
think it was going to hit me that hard
dude and dude that [__] hit me hard when
we got to LX fool I was just swaying dog
so I went home fool I'm all let me take
a little nap fool and the thing that I
[__] up is I didn't set the alarm dog
but I had my little phone right here and
I'm going take a 15minute nap fo I woke
up at 9:30 with text where are you is
everything okay hello I was like [__]
idiot I'm like oh and I was all stupid
fool I was like all right so you want
here let me take jump in the shower and
I'll go meet up with you so uh no um I'm
tired I'm going to go to bed I was like
[__] idiot and then it didn't hit me
till I woke up in the morning what a
[__] [__] dog [__] and then she
forgave me though damn so you told her
I'm going to get ready we didn't get
ready oh no no I told her cuz I woke at
9:30 but we're supposed to go out like
at 8: it was an hour and a half later
and then she was like [__] dude I'm
tired I'm going to go to bed
[__] so I was like [__] dog I'm
sorry sounds like a good idea you said
huh I didn't think it was going to hit
me that hard dog I thought it would wear
out by the time we get back dude you
should have went over there and like a
little turtle and C with
her well knocking out the door she lives
at home do I um I I forgot I forgot to
call someone back like that and they
call me all day what happened I never
called them back and they want to time I
keep saying I'll call him back I call
him back but they didn't call him back
then then after a while man I just it
just became too long I said I'm then I
just going to call forget it I'm just
going to make this disappear and um
think everything's going to disappear
and every the message where are you
Felipe are you
alive I mean I know we're not serious or
anything between us but I mean let me
know if you're okay not serious you just
disappeared of the earth and were you
what were you doing did you you didn't
need or nothing right no I just I just I
don't know man I was with in Arizona
with you I guess I don't know but I just
didn't call back I mean I don't know I
just didn't feel like I it wasn't that I
didn't feel like calling just that
something told you deep inside were over
it I never know the girl was cute and
all that but I just they didn't call
stopped calling
just disappeared nothing nothing nothing
she did it was everything I did I did
not call her back but we we only went
out one time but I guess you know there
would to be more dates uhhuh cuz it was
cool cuz it was one of those days where
there was no sex no making out nothing
nothing well he used to make fun of me
for not getting kisses dog well I
tried well I didn't try I don't know why
I didn't try I just didn't feel like a
date dat to me uh-huh so that way when I
didn't call it didn't I didn't feel
anything either so what the chemistry
was gone
I don't know if there was chemistry but
um this CH was already telling people
I'm with
Felipe you want to go to the red carpet
event and get her dress ready do she at
the last Factory somewhere and then the
other comedian came around I'm I'm
spoken for I'm with felip I even got a
text Bro there some [__] chick saying
you're a lady well F they're trying to
Hound on her or what bro you know
sometime when a woman doesn't have a
ring sh to make her
boyfriends and if I have to be that
boyfriend I'll be that boyfriend who was
it I don't know man I never saw her
again
oh fool her sister was the chick that
has sex with was that Navy guy and
what's his
name the guy the guy with the thong
Daryl Black Shear yeah who the [__] was
she fool I don't remember her name
anymore but I just know cuz it just came
to me like that's right her sister was
going through a divorce and she was like
going crazy so she took that Navy guy
inside that car and then her right hit
off cuz I guess you wasn't a
[__] fing Redemption but that was but
that was weird because I didn't call her
back and then when I did call her back
it was already too late she was just
like over it yeah over it like I lost a
lot of relationship like that just
stopped calling oh yeah
disappearing it felt like um and then
later on when I would dream I would
dream that I was never with them more or
we never were together or did I really
meet you did I really know you are you
with somebody else or what no just the
dream I just want forget man you think
well you you you you you feel that way
because it just it just fizzled there
was nothing on the other side or what
just sax or just I don't know
man no emotional contact but I I I get
like that sometimes you know like um
I'll stop calling my mom or or my dad or
my family members and then like years go
by but you can't race those fools though
that's the thing it's only difference
though
or like just like J Diaz he calls every
week except this week [__] sucker the
[__] is going on bro [__] busy man I
got a new nose well you [__] working
Sundays I talked to him in the morning
fool what's up fool rrio B we came back
from New York it was [__] hot over
there Papa Um Papa it was umid we hung
up with Lisa Lisa and the co jam oh hell
yeah F I thought that F was lying dog me
too man Oh I thought you knew I thought
it was going to be one of those um Kings
of Leon stories
bro [__] liar dog yeah so shout out
to the funny Latino comedian Romanesque
real cool guy Roman Suarez from huarez
how' you meet that fool I met that fool
on Instagram oh really he hit you up oh
okay for some reason I thought you met
him last time you were in New York who's
this mustache
Pete has a little strong man mustache
huh so did I saw him oh dude so we hung
out with him and Lisa Lisa coach no we
ran into that food yeah we were on the
street we were on the streets we're
walking with my mom we were by
rockefella looking for Pokemon looking
for Pokemon this F creeped out of
nowhere bro probably were fight
following our
Snapchat like
no I had a meeting with a with a comedy
club I haven't putting my show up Papa
it's nice to see you it's like a
blessing yeah so we're hanging out with
Mama espara oh my God yes
Mama we at the Mexican restaurant called
Blockheads that [__] was horrible
horrible man it was a lot of man it was
a waste it wasn't that good huh they say
[__] Mexican food sucks in New York
it really sucks it sucks man anybody
right there man anybody out there
listening who's in the drug business and
want to get out of the drug business and
to go legit I suggest you take your your
some your mom who knows how to cook
Mexican food and buy a smallest closet
you can find in Manhattan and sell
decent Mexican food over there but then
again the decent Mexican food that we
like other people might not like it
though oh yeah they want crunch Lisa
said she grew up with only crunch tacos
oh yeah that's [__] Taco Tuesday
tacos she didn't know takito bro like
King Taco till she got to La little
tortilla tacos talk about how great it
was with your mom but then she ruin in
the car yesterday
I was like we had a wonderful time at
the at the at the Manhattan was back my
mom showed up Chris toino hey bro dude I
love your mom bro remember he was going
to get adopted
H we were hanging out in ch Square as
soon as we got there we went to CH
Square didn't we yeah yeah it was hot
we walked around Rodrigo took a pizza
home four slices that F ate them yeah
[__] forget about it dog what that fool
say everything dog you can't front dog
[__] pizza here sucks dog it is the
the water right I guess so water it's a
water because New York water I don't
know how how a place over there can get
probably from the Everglades no it's cuz
it sits on the rooftops it's cleaner
doesn't go through the pipes down below
yeah I seen a bunch of Theos up there on
those buildings do yeah over here we got
water that look like orchata bro it's
all [__] cloudy just in right now
from Flint Michigan we just saw some bad
news last night not only there not only
do they have bad water okay now bad
water still continues by the way I know
we haven't talked about the last first
time we talked about um the Flint
problem last year it's still going on
now the trash company doesn't want to
pick up the trash anymore because they
made a bad deal with the city so they're
on strike so don't was picking up trash
in the city of flint and they were
talking to some black lady and she was
doing an interview I don't know where to
put my trash but the sad thing was when
she was doing an interview about where
she going to put that trash behind her
there was like 7 feet of bottle water
stacked up together boxes like there's
still no water they must want Detroit
and flit Michigan to slowly dissolve to
the point where nobody wants to live
there and just bring in money huh
something's up dude but [__] their
little government's [__] [__] dog
they're [__] up dog I mean [__]
[__] [__] are paying their
taxes and they have a [__] uh a deal
with the [__] uh trash company and
then on the [__] day that the deal's
over those [__] say [__] you
we're not picking up the trash come on
fool Miss management like a [__]
dog where's John G when you need him bro
[__]
dead see when the M was running these
trash cans bro they was always picked up
hell yeah they was always picked up cuz
the contracts were always solid dog
solid bro I what we need we need so much
to break next we need some gangsters we
need a president to come in not like
Donald Trump be all racist but be all
hard bro hell yeah don't put down R
nationalities but put down the
establishment go you know what get to
work fool listen man I am rich and I'm
going to tell you how my how I got rich
but let's all get rich yeah fool give
them the [__] recipe just not a
[__] piece of the [__] pie already
dog I just want to weet my beak you know
just a little bit a little bit but so
[__] when we went to New York what we
did [__] Time Square first we creep
with your mom that day the next day what
can we hit the Empire State building
we've been to Coney
Island I I haven't hung up I haven't
hung out with my mom like that since we
hung out
in 2004 I went to Orlando Florida with
Gabriel glaas and his mother and my
mother and Ivan and Gabriel's sister and
Gabriel and my mom they Gabriel's mom
and my mom sat together on the plane and
they talked about eating frog legs and
lizards and snakes and cows GR you know
everybody in a
plane it a good time man I felt like a
kid again I never f i i I haven't had
the the mother and mother and son
feeling in wow 20 years long ass time
cuz you grow old and you become a drug
addict and then you clean up and then
you become a drug addict again and so
then then later on you you become a big
drug addict and then you don't want your
mom to see that you're a drug addict so
you stop coming around your mom's house
you call once a month twice a month then
you stop calling then um you just stop
calling it all and then your mom starts
calling you but you don't pick up you
know this a a real weird parent and some
relationship that we have going cuz I
hold a lot of regrets from when I was a
kid you know but I put it all behind me
in New York man a going to lie man it
was sad saying bye to my mom every time
I went back to my room I wanted she
wanted me to spend the night and say
come
on it's cuz dick you're still her son
fool regardless of how old
you I'm thinking to myself but what are
we going to go get high at right
now don't you know your your son needs a
little
dab so I was like hoping I was like man
if I I wish I could just do a dab and
then go lay with my mom like a little
rabbit your mom doesn't know you smoke F
hell no I'm pretty sure she had an idea
right but I try to I didn't really get
high that much around her in New York I
wanted to be I don't want to be like oh
I got to be higher around my mom we have
a good time so I try to be sober and I
did and it was all good you know we're
having a good time I love my mother she
had a wonderful time if you guys saw me
on Snapchat we were all over the place
and it too dog she's going to be 70 bro
yeah looks good
damn and um what else yeah who's all
good bro I I was like it was hard to say
goodbye you know Dro in the off you know
like I want to cry got used to her but
then I got but then when we were in the
car she brought up that my brother was
born in the same birthday and then I got
[__] start getting more mad than the
real like where the hate is
from then she keps saying over and over
like her side of it over again like you
bring her back the old argument just to
let you know she said that um Cho know
first of all she called me Chito which
is my nickname and she didn't call me
all that that name all the time we're in
New York she brings it up in the
carito
you guys cuz they didn't make you a cake
right yeah bro cuz see man I watch too
much TV
bro like when you turns 18 in the TV
they buy you a car a this one not
everybody gets a car fool my brother got
one with the little one no angel are you
serious fool damn that forgot everything
dog he got life
bro
that fool got a car fo damn F Pap dog
all right bro see you on my side now
okay let's keep
moving I didn't think he got a car I
didn't think anybody he got a car for
this is how funny ass [__] my brother my
brother he didn't Lo me the car bro I
took off of his car dog D it's m too dog
and not only that I didn't give a [__]
bro I let my black friend Coco drive
that car time we were driving my dad was
crossing the street and my dad was
crossing the the street my black friend
Coco was driving he just mad doged us I
said we should have ran that full over
big dog damn for did he get mad cuz of
hell yeah a black food he thought we
stole the
car so we're back in the car and my mom
brings up that [__] right and then I'm
like all right all right all right but
see what got me more Angry it wasn't
just the fact that they forgot my
birthday my brother was born on the same
day as me okay as me but it ain't just
that he [__] up your day it was like
that movie 16 Candles when the sister
was getting married the next day after
her birthday so the day before the
birthday nobody told her happy birthday
not even the dad the dad all late and
[__] when she was sleeping in the couch
remember Marley ring she said oh forgot
it's your birthday but nobody told me
bro I ain't going to lie my mom said she
tried to call me when the hospital fool
that [__] happened to me twice when
nobody in my family told me happy
birthday
dog where your family at bro at a
[__] Rodeo [__] I don't [__] know
dog nobody called me or nothing dog I
saw one time Jerry and Vinnie just took
me out but I had [__] to do but I was
like [__] I kind of felt weird like dude
it's all [__] good and my mom
saido no Mom is I was like F I had a
little league game that day right so I
got home I got my little league gear and
I went to a baseball game cuz I was
playing semi pro dog old you I was
playing a 16year old to 19y old League
damn F I was just 18 looking all County
over here so I was playing every
Saturdays I would play at Pico
Rivera um Sports Pico Rivera Park and
those guys over there man they're all
older 25 they're older man like pisas
they're [__] good
bro seven home runs off of us back to
damn far bro I got tired of chasing the
ball so I had a game that night we lost
and I still have my baseball uniform on
and my that's it where were you at and I
like I tell him I told him you see what
am I wearing you [__] right so um
that fol pushed me to the ground for and
my [__] and I [__] hit my head on the
stairs dog so that was my 18th birthday
dude so yeah I'm going hold it back a
little
bit nobody say sorry
Yet [__] it we have New York baby [__]
yeah New York was tight dog but I'm GL I
got to have my like my own mom and son
more with just her and I not the other
[__] but you know she's going
to tell everybody how good she had time
in New York she has to Bro the food
can't stop
that she's GNA be
like she'll say some [__] at that dog
you know she's going to tell say yeah my
son took me to New York you guys want me
a babysit and that's where the fight
start she's going to tell him about the
canoli she ate do
man
old little foot old man damn dog that's
hilarious F Yeah man so should we went
back to the house we had a good
time it was fun hell yeah dude guys gave
her some jack fruit tacos jack fruit
tacos people yeah
man how's the bunny rabbit dog my bunny
is good bro you got all happy when all
happy
chilling yeah man we were staying three
people in a room it was tight fo we were
the three of us were staying in a bed
well no I had like a queen-sized bed and
on the side of me there was two bunk
beds was like we were in a dorm fol and
Chris th had the
ladder fuing Chucky
dog yeah man it was so hot but they said
that the [__] Heat Wave was a week
before dog wow I don't know what this
was but it was burning wave yeah it was
and then it was raining remember
fool that was a wor when it was raining
it was still 96° what part what you like
better fool out of all the spots we went
to I like the Empire State Building that
that that's what you like the best yeah
I like the boat ride it was an hour too
long oh fool I forgot about the boat
ride we' seen the Statue of Liberty dog
we went to around the whole area right
yeah all over New York dude it took two
hours and a
half it was an hour too long Hau yeah it
was long man yeah after that I was just
like [__] and then they didn't [__]
have no pretzels and it took them three
hours to make a [__] pretzel
oh my God man the the they had a they
had food on the boat with the slowest
people ever that lady will cook five
pretzel at a time 200 people there you
know what she told me for I only got two
arms I was like what the [__] I was like
look at the [__] pretzel machine 20
PR pretzels can fit in there you only
put [__] five whatever dude man she
was taking a long time making nachos
tooo oh dude and they were even [__]
putting cheese on those [__]
those those lady were older than me
right A F come on they were pushing 60
dog cuz they shouldn't be back there huh
[__] tired with old ass hips oh side to
side dude come on dog any CH that wears
a baseball hat like that come on get the
[__] out of here get in the bleachers
already see that that she had that job
because young kids don't want to work
there oh [__] no dude but they also have
those jobs they're not going to give it
till they up till they die dog something
happens probably
Union I think it was who we got
recognized by a cop at Coney Island oh
yeah dog that the Asian went to the
freak Show baby a the freak Show dog
what that contortion is Dog the human
Gumby oh that was [__] crazy that fol
got inside of a [__] tennis racket
dog oh yeah that was [__] tell at
least it was a ring but it was a tennis
racket dude this [__] dude
flipped his [__] shoulder inside out
dog [__] he rotated it and then he put
his legs and his arm and he flipped it
over the other side yeah he got into it
like in his waist fool that's some real
freak Show [__] h yeah that was I never
seen that before that kind of freaked me
out I was like [__] now you you can make
money off that for the rest of your life
that fool can I should have got that
badass poster though yeah that would
have been cool disappeared though real
quick but the um then what the yo-yo
[__] CH yo-yo guy was good he was
cool he um in the fire breather he was
cool how was the the big girl with the
thighs H she the only all right the only
thing I didn't like about it was it I'm
cool if you get on there without a shirt
and you might get some Nails into you
but she had like a little a little vest
on that was designed for the nails not
to penetrate her and then they put the
skinny fo on top of her they should have
put a fat fool on top of her I would
have but SC I would have dud I would
have do dog I know they put the
skinniest person on top of her yeah how
do they do it when they get on glass I
don't know fool that's another way but I
mean [__] glass can [__] you up more
than nails and they were Nails fool but
they're galvanized nails but they were
the thick ones they're not little thin
nails or she would have [__] went
through my I don't think my mom could
take that guy nailing his nail through
his nose oh that was [__] crazy I
didn't like oh [__] dude but you know
what don't you have a cavity in there
where you can slide it in and [__]
you have do a that coke I was like [__]
that one was weird dog I was like Jo
Diaz could do with a
broomstick that's right [__] suckers but
you know what was [__] bad about the
whole freak Show F was their little band
dog oh yeah they were bad as [__] dog
hell yeah they got that [__] playing
guitar and drums yeah dude and had a
good music going on dude I recorded a
little bit you want to [__] listen to
it yeah hey all right I recorded So of
too but it didn't take it all the way I
thought that [__] [__] was [__]
cool when we got to puny Island man my
mom had a a Nathan's dog oh I forgot and
they were good she said they were good
she had it without no ketchup and no
mustard exactly I my mom likes she don't
like putting stuff on the hot
dog anybody out there I met people who
like their hamburgers just their meat
with the burger and no man no ketchup no
onions just playing
this is the band that was
playing so this music was
playing the guy was being a
contortionist that sh was it remind me
of the the monsters yeah The Groovy
Ghoulies they were cool
dog they were awesome bro Bas guitar and
drums yeah basic
cool yeah first car
little taste of Coney Island
everybody first
caller hello
you what's up fool who's this what's up
fo what's up fool over here watching you
dog here B real TV smoking while we're
watching you doing the live podcast
what's up fool this is the homie world
the one I mentioned last week they gave
the biggest dab known to L to humankind
are you serious this is the F what up
dog
what up dog see chill you dog I wanted
to call in cuz you guys were talking
about you have a dibre under the table
and
[__] bring it dog we don't have a I want
I want to take you some good [__]
because you know well he told me that
story when you walked into green wolf
and [__] and you were say you were
saying that like they don't even want
like they don't even hook you up but you
know those F watch you on Netflix and
[__] yeah yeah dog like that's not right
dog they should hook you up not right
that that's I know bro that ain't right
I should get a t-shirt or something
yeah dog at least a sweater I have like
10 of them
dog hell yeah bro so where you guys at
right now you got that be real TV right
now yeah man we have our our live show
going on at four o'clock over here
smoking some weed with the doctor and
[__] [__] that's right man I think me
and Rodrigo got to make a little pissed
up on the way on the way when we get out
of here you guys know you're welcome
over here anytime man come smoke off and
[__] we have some artistic rigs tell
Rodrigo oh [__] yeah dude well text us
your number on in Instagram but we'll go
after the show and hang out cuz um
sounds good man go I'll go ahead and
I'll text you and then we'll come dab it
up tell rodo to be ready dog he's ready
bro [__] yeah hell yeah all right what's
up up what's up fool what's your name
again ezone all right oh it's ezone
bro eone don't don't hold back bro that
F just go
and hell yeah bro cuz I got a new needle
I got from the joint
bencher you need to get that quartz one
dog see I'm I'm going break you down the
science of this [__] dog break it down
bro look man A lot of people are going
to still smoking off the metal [__] they
need to go ahead and go to the to the
Crystal Court [__] why is that that's
the it's like the one that looks like
you know if you go to Chinatown they
have all of them it look like they're
made out of glass but the real ones are
made out of Crystal cord yeah they
they're white right get sick making it
okay is it has the right temp the
perfect temperature for a dab or what
dude it holds it perfectly yeah we have
timers for that that [__]
really yeah [__] you you guys need a
head down over here man I am
down [__] yeah hell yeah ezone thank you
ezone what's up people check me out on B
real TV live with B real on the
smokeout on the hot box also on the
smoke out also check out the other
interview I did with B real TV and go to
their Network And
subscribe yeah yeah what's up all right
man thank you keep doing what you're
doing man thank you bro we got to have
be real on this
podcast hell yeah man we have some
dabbers [__] dog forget about it dog
that's the iron lung bro oh
D yeah man we'll see you guys in a bit
stop man thank you all right he on be
cool dog keep shining they have the
thing that press too that's what you're
telling me about how they [__] get
the THC out what's up fool
Yello
hello what up fo what's up up who's
this from Detroit Detroit we're just
talking about Detroit dog what's
happening over there with the trash and
[__] they picking it
up man this [__] broke man ain't got no
money for that [__] man so it is that
[__] bad
dude yeah like like man the money the
money on the black maret a no money in
there in the real Market damn dude and
what up with the water still messed
up oh no that was up in S I don't know
what's going on up there that's like a
couple hours away okay hey what's the
name of that restaurant you ate in
Detroit Sweet Water
Tavern yeah Sweet Water yeah yeah they
got the best chicken wings hell yeah
they made they marinade them for 24
hours it's right across the street from
St Andrew's hall and then around the
corner is be's comedy
kitchen yeah I've been there 96 and 98
dog bomb ass [__] chicken wings where
y'all coming to Michigan man what's up
fol I'm coming to Michigan with with
Mike EPS as the in February I'm doing
like a opening set he's he's going to be
the headliner and there's another
comedian and I'm like a special guest
doing like 15 to 20
minutes I Gotta Give me some tiies dog
yeah man [__] yeah dog Detroit baby
that's where what's it name from Tommy
Chun Tommy [__] Chun
yeah me and R be there hell yeah we'll
be chill I'll be chilling post it dog
yeah dog [__] a eight M like a
[__] dog take us
cruising Devil's Night Before Halloween
out there dog don't they light it up
still say what Devil's Night Before
Halloween the day before Halloween the
Night Before Halloween oh yeah the
police be trying to shut that down
though like all trying to sh it down
still
damn
really so they be and how long they'
been trying to put put a stop to
that it's been a while since I was a kid
probably yeah cuz they said they used
should get [__] crazy after you know
talking to the locals and the people
that came out to see my homies banned
and [__] but dude they said [__]
badass Devils nights though a couple
[__] years in a row back in the
day I thought that was devil nights in
Detroit was just a movie n f they get
crazy the Night Before Halloween dog
[__] robbing people [__] [__] up
lighting [__] on fire breaking Windows
[__] bombing cars like I thought it
was a movie no it was for real well that
they made the movie from that I saw that
movie I said God damn I'm never going to
Detroit yeah it was for real I didn't
know they had a
movie when they come I've never seen the
movie yeah they have a movie called that
where everybody get getting together
they having a meeting yeah fool it was
all [__] planned out and [__] they
just [__] raising hell dog yeah man
[__] yeah well hell yeah play boy thank
you so much for calling in thank you for
checking out the podcast dog on the real
quick question man do they do they have
abandoned Auto auto factories there
where nobody where homeless
live yeah yeah there's a bunch of
abandoned factories all type of abandon
business C feel like it's
abandon yeah I think I I saw that
Anthony bouraine in Detroit on
Netflix they got squatters up in there
yeah they do yeah squatter everywhere
it's it's squatters and houses you would
think it was their actual
house you know quiet yeah know the neigh
and
everything yeah yeah my mom got a couple
of squaders bro they call
relatives don't even pay rent but drink
all the milk and orange
juice one quick question big dog man
what's up with the puff the the puff
situation out there The Bu the weed
situation you got some good [__] over
there of course they do it's
legal I mean it's legal you got the car
but I ain't got no card I see
smoke but it's good out there coming
from out there coming from C really so
okay okay you guys getting it shipped
out there all right all
right I went to a shop in Traver City
yeah that's when you s sent me that uh
picture of the quarter in the in the
butt how big it was yeah oh yeah [__]
yeah dog yeah man give us up what's up
fool what's up fool what's up fool
Detroit Rock City [__] yeah oh yeah man
thank you for listening to inala the
cero podcast too bro we have a new
episode I like that I like the AEL lot
of cero I like I like you Le
relationship man y got a nice
relationship man keep that here oh thank
you very much man I'll let her know
she's right here by the way all
right thank you bro all right
peace that was nice we had a call from
Detroit [__] yeah cool I feel like cool
man I feel like I'm talking to somebody
in the world bro yeah F I mean dick I
get the I get the chills bro like
Detroit it's like I feel like [__] yeah
I got friends in Detroit I love Detroit
dog I went to yeah man Detroit I went to
Windsor Windsor what's up
fo what's up fo what up all the way from
the Moes right no pale Palmdale oh yeah
Palmdale how's the heat out there
it's me
again who is
this um Tony calling from Palmdale oh
what's up Tony from Palmdale how's pale
how you been good everything's good just
calling in to check in on you guys we're
doing good man we have the podcast going
we're going to do the one hour special
August 27 at the at the San Jose
Improv okay since I've already gotten
through before I'm G to make it short so
everybody gets a chance but I have a
couple questions yes Tony are you gonna
help Rodrigo do the Yelp review on the
roach
motel yes we are give a [__] par get
that police report
going police we are man I think uh one
of those roaches took out with one of
our
t-shirts put cuffs on those fools and
you know what on your last podcast you
had with the Chinese girl um you read a
review from someone that was talking
about how she Compares I don't know if
it was a girl or a guy but they compare
your show to like Howard Stern and stuff
and actually they beat me to the punch
because that's exactly what I was going
to tell you the entertainment I only
listen to Howard
Stern wel F podcast in cero and the Y
Man podcast so that's what's up I just
wanted to let you know that I feel the
same way thank you thank you so much
thank you Tony from Palm hardcore
listener we love you [__] and thank you
Rodrigo the last time I got a shout out
and you were the only one who pronounced
my last name right because my Instagram
name was T Hawk is and you said it right
right on thank you so much uh right back
at you what's her last name hwz
hawz t hawz Miss T hawz thank you miss
one more thing are we gonna get a
catchphrase for I in casserole for Lisa
since we already got
and yeah we're going to think about one
right now we're going to have to work on
one for her we will man we will all
right hi Lisa you guys take care right
on say
hi all right that was liers well let
someone else could oh one more thing on
one of your post for the the call in
show the number's correct on the picture
but on the where you type to call in
that one's wrong okay my bad the
Snapchat that's off okay thank you all
right guys take care have a nice
hins that was cool man she's cool
too yeah
helloa what's up
F what's up what's up F who's this
Xavier from Seattle Xavier from Seattle
got in like Flynn how's Seattle man
how's
life beautiful man sunny out here I love
it man I can't wait to go over there to
the Parlor bar
right man I can't wait to you come over
man we always have fun out here hell
yeah anyway so this is actually for
Rodrigo man yes uh so Rodrigo man the
first time I ever saw you do stand up
bro uh you know it wasn't all that good
man but all the few times after that man
you've been on point
bro thank you man well what happened
man oh man you were getting at some some
first time I saw you man yeah it wasn't
too good where you where did you see me
at at The Parlor in I yeah was the first
time we were there I think with Le I was
I wearing a Raider hat and had like kind
of long hair yeah it was a bad phase bro
I'm
sorry mustache too you laughing
now I don't think I had a mustache in
that one yeah the [__] mustache was
[__] horrible dog that mustach look
like [__]
tape oh we tight t-shirts too
this [__] dog [__] breaking
down the set dog wardrobe over here dog
what what he really say bro your timing
is on point to thank you man yeah man
and he what he really say he wants you
to he wants to hear more impersonations
in your act and this is what this is
what happens fol every new city that I
hit dude I'm kind of afraid like you
don't want to [__] you know you want
to [__] be liked and do good you
don't want to get [__] too [__]
crazy or whatever so you know that could
have been that too but I mean [__] it
thank you very much for the [__] a
constructive criticism in the love dog
it's all gravy dog it's all good it's
all good man well you guys keep doing
what you're doing man I'll see you guys
in Seattle when you guys get down there
absolutely hell yeah bro thank you very
much man I feel like every time I go to
Seattle or somewhere where everybody
giving away weed I feel like I got to
like need like a a cleansing bro like we
go to when we go to remember we went
somewhere it was a San Jose and like iy
just no like guy just showed up and gave
her like a coder yeah yeah yeah and then
like we we can't take this home we got
to cat catch a PL yeah well they they
give us a weed the day before we're
going to take off I know man that sucks
they should have G that show where he
got there [__] I know bers can't be
choosing get all [__] smoked out dog
or hide it [__] yeah next time we been
diing about that app if we can [__]
freeze dry that [__] yeah what's up
fool hey what's up fool what's up who's
this [__] this Loreno from chot Town El
Paso or or live from Cho tacos Cho tacos
chos bro hey bro I just want to say uh
[__] B read
bro this [__] dog why F why dog
oh I went to go see Willie down there
and I guess apparently he cut him off
bro I was trying to buy Willie a shot
when he was down there and like Willie
cut him off and he's like nah man so
that was [__] up bro I so he didn't
let you give Willie the shot willly a
shot nah that sucks apparently yeah yeah
how was Willie man mad uh I don't know
man get before the night before like
that Thursday night show or Friday night
show like he SC a party with her he he
could drink but the next day that to
wrestle and what did he get too [__]
up to show the night
before I think so that's probably what
happened so [__] I think bartk cut
him off so yeah man we try to buy him a
shot or some drinks man and like no
really like bro I can't drink I'm like
damn fool [__] up I heard I heard
there was an incident where he fell into
the crowd or
something uh yeah probably so
man sure but yeah he was falling for you
dog [__] Bart re [__] Bart Reed
broy pooper party pooper that's funny
man he'll cut off somebody's alcohol but
he will put a AC in The Green Room hey
fo remember when the ceiling tile fell
on you fo the ceiling tile fell on me in
the green room cuz he had a [__] oh
[__] like there's there's a hole in the
wall [__] ghetto
dog that [__] is funny man that's all I
wanted to say man just what I want to
say what's up love the show man thank
you dog was [__] cut me off bro you
didn't even let me taste it
bro I want to
B thank you bro stay live hell yeah F
that [__] was funny though
see this show is helping that food too
dog of course fool we're not saying
anything bad about him we're saying
support him go to his show yeah dog tell
him we said hello hell yeah I mean dick
he cook the mob what's up fool what's up
what's up man where you at dude I'm the
only Mexican from the FV in Mississippi
God sh what's up
Mississippi what's going on I'm so
[__] happy to be talking to you guys
right now you have no idea fck any good
Mexican food in Mississippi
hell yeah dude I'm [__] holding down
by myself down here in [__] Clan
land damn what are you doing out there
fool he work in an oil company long
story dude my U my my mom my sister been
married for like 25 years and uh when he
met my mom he just stayed in California
then a couple years ago decided they're
gonna come out
here I Ed out here too damn
damn you're the only Mexican over there
no there's like I know I've seen a
couple
there's not that many though what's the
weather over there hot huh it's [__]
hot as [__] it's like right now it's
like uh 100% humidity and like 96 and
just imagine bro those slaves worked all
year I know fool something with no
T-shirt imagine having a a burn sweat a
sunburn and getting whipped for free dog
no no man Bill O'Reilly said bro they
had nice quars when they built the White
House [__] is he talking about remember
that when um Michelle Obama said that um
it's proud to see my my daughters play
in his backyard the White House which
was buil by black slaves and then Bill
Riley said why did she have to say that
why do you have to bring that it's a
fact this my last my last speech I might
as well get it right anyway so yeah I
was just um up in Memphis it's like
three hours from here they have the Cil
R Museum and I went up there last
weekend and they have all the packs and
all that stuff they build everything
back then oh [__] oh wow our country's
[__] Capital was built on [__]
cotton money
exactly cotton all that [__] hell yeah
fool hell yeah what part of Mr you from
uh right now I'm in um I'm in Jackson
well just outside of
jacksonon oh [__] yeah dog that's where
the word comes from hey Jackson probably
dude and I know uh uh Johnny Cash and
June uh Carter Cash do that song I'm
going to Jackson pretty cool song yeah
yeah yeah Action Jackson Carl Weathers
dog Michael Jackson hey rrio what's up
fol do you know a dude from [__]
Riverside named Jake Michaels Jacob
Michaels yeah yeah F I went to school
with them dog I actually seen him like
one of my good friends when I lived when
I was still living in California are you
serious F I seen him probably like a
year ago we car pulled to work every day
for like three years really yeah F I
know that for I know his mom dude his
dad [__] my homie Justin frer his
made your I made your homie fraker
through him
yeah well who'd you guys go see dog we
saw um Jake Jake's wife wouldn't let him
go so Jake gave the to Freer ah the
first wife right the first wife the
Italian chick that went crazy oh dude
one that beat his ass dude heard she's a
[__] monster dog dude she was a [__]
dude she would kick him out like on
Tuesday nights she' kick him out of the
house fo in the car used to clown him
all the time because of that [__] [__]
up I because I felt bad because I got
along with him really other for
real be like some black on Tuesday night
oh yeah dude [__] it's crazy though
and but we went and saw we went saw the
poges at the Grove in an the poges so
that was you fool all right dude the
poges yeah fo they play up the Groves
[__] fre like yeah D I got it was
Christmas
evening oh [__] yeah we'll sing a song
Chas guitar we had one time [__] that
song makes me cry bro
yeah not that's [__] I want to play at
my funeral damn F let's not go there yet
[__] far too far away but [__] yeah
dog that's what's up dog yeah I know
that fo dog yeah dude but you guys keep
me staying out here bro like you guys
[__] remind me of home and [__] like
a little bit of home that I get out here
is you guys man thank you man [__] yeah
dog always here hopefully if you guys
come if you come to New Orleans or if
you go to Birmingham again that's like
three hours from here I'm trying to make
it up there again [__] yeah we might be
going to New Orleans because I'm opening
up for for uh Mike EPS next year like in
April for like a couple I'm opening up
for um Bruce Bruce some more Mike EPs
and Ricky Smiley and one of the dates is
in New Orleans and Rodrigo going to come
just hang out so we're going to well
[__] that's like two that's like two
hours from here go we'll post it up when
it when the DAT comes yeah hit us up
keep us posted you know we'll [__]
we'll meet up dog yeah man hell yeah
that' be cool [__] all right guys
[__] uh yeah dude keep doing your
thing man love you guys right on right
back at you dude keep trying go hang out
bro go break some windows right
man that was the thing to do here kid
bro I love breaking Windows [__] love
breaking Windows I'm going to go break
some windows right now I wouldn't break
windows people still living there but
like buildings ah F there used to be a
park where they had junk cars throw
[__] break the windows going with a
sledgehammer smashing the door bro I
love [__] [__] up dog I could be a
demolition BR bro you could be the
maachi brothers hey fool you know the
movie po fiction when he goes drops off
the body of the car right there and the
dude that's the [__] I love junkyards
fool hell yeah man shooting at those
always want to me a dirty ass junkyard
dog
bro like the one like the kind of food
the kind of dog that eats all his meals
out out of the out of the um the the
rims yeah they have the food right there
it's a bowl yeah [__] yeah a dirty
[__] bro like but nice just bar
at everybody with sharp ass
teeth this like that dog like that dog
in Planes Trains automobiles remember
when you get a ride when he goes
um what's up
fool what's up P lower the computer dog
yeah I got you I got you
what it do what it do what it do fool
where you
from htown baby Houston dog Houston he's
over there we have a
problem the floods are
coming what's happening dog what's your
name dog n man Joel I listen to you guys
all the time man been trying to get
through this line for for about an hour
here I'm glad you got in h what's up
Joel chilling over there man I went to Y
show last time man I made you do the dab
oh that's right inside the green
room I don't know I remember oh we were
standing in line yeah standing in line
man I was the one with the big nose yeah
you had that pen you had the cool ass
pen yeah hell yeah man I hit that [__]
dude that was good it hit me a little
while after but it hit me good dog it
hit me too what's up fol what's up man
he man when y'all coming back to the age
I don't know when we're coming back to
the age probably um in next
may but um San Antonio I'll be in
November I'll proba ahead up there with
you guys man we'll be here we'll be
there I just want to say you guys are
doing the big man keep it up thank you
Joel in aown baby [__] you thank you for
all the love and support dog hey I
wanted I want to see when you guys were
G to come down to U ofh game
man University of Houston University of
Houston football game when y'all GNA
come out to see one are the games I
don't know maybe if weing when we're out
there we can [__] match something up
dog but I mean we'll [__] keep you
posted on that I didn't know they had a
team yeah it gets crazy right fool it
gets insane huh come on man they play at
Texas they play at Texas stadium yeah
dude where the Houston
play uh the Texans man that's where they
play L yeah oh hell yeah dude exactly
dude do they get crazy though like tell
getting
parties yeah man bunch of crazy meic
down here bro I like to see that hell
yeah dude I know I saw that crazy
Mexican um um college football fight in
you at utip with the old man what
happened the old guy you saw that right
it was youp it was UTP against Houston
right the the the university I don't
know I don't know if it was Houston it
was another Boise I think UTP I think it
was Texas T or something yeah it was
Texas against UTP and the old man was on
UTP and was he was old man fighting
young fool bro who won nobody bro nobody
a lot of people got beat up though a lot
a lot of fat fools were falling bro with
no balance you could tell who can fight
bro the ones that were falling had no
balance weak ankles dog and white
hips that's why just stay in the back
with the ladies yeah [__] all that soon
as she buy that wine I make from behind
who you be with what's up
fool what's up fool man hey man but uh I
just wanted to get through man I know
it's hard to get through these lines I
just wanted to give a give a shout out
to y'all man just uh wanted to get on
and just say you guys are are doing the
big man I always listening to all your
podcast and uh we got a whole bunch of
other people that that listen to it all
here in Houston and uh and the CH man so
um I always joke with everybody with
y'all's phrases and stuff like that so I
tend to pick up on y'all's uh on your
slang man for some reason for listening
to so much that's what's up yeah for
real I'm always out there talking with
people I say yeah
man hell yeah hell yeah yeah man I I I
always tell my girl I'm like hey uh you
wanto or something I don't know I don't
know I pick up I pick up the slam hell
yeah hell yeah bro it's like that first
cyers Hill wck record dog the lat and
lingo no but uh you guys are doing the
me man I just want to congratulate y'all
um you doing it big for the for the
Mexicans man out there and the Hispanic
community so uh keep doing it and um hey
if you guys ever come down man you guys
are welcome to to hit me up bro you guys
uh come to U gam or something I'm a big
fan so you guys are welcome to come out
here or just come kick it in the H thank
you for the invite that's what's up
dog hell yeah hell yeah F keep shining
dog htown htown htown hell yeah all
right y go co man y'all y'all keep it up
right on dog to said what's up say B say
hello to Baby
Bash all right man laters
what's up fool next
caller hello what's up
do hello
hello yeah what's up what's up what's up
fool you're a toilet or
what
it's got what's upo what's up dog what's
going on man hey uh s want to say uh
Rodrigo for for a good minute um just
wanted to do a quick story um I kind of
heard you on Pandora and I was L to your
podcast with PK and you was like hey how
am I going to get on or how I'm G to get
exposed and then when you brought up the
whole Pandora um story that was pretty
cool they kind of relate to that because
they're on a road trip and I heard you
on Pandora and listen to you ever since
so got a lot of respect for you you know
what I mean so it's pretty cool what
you're doing thank you and I've been
listening to your podcast enchilada
Castro and the podcast so it's pretty
cool I mean pretty cool hearing you guys
and getting your stories and
feedback thank you for listening to the
what so fo family hell yeah dude thank
you very much yeah just a quick Story
another one I'm
sorry trying to get through I know
you're a vegan you and your wife Lisa
want to say what's up to Lisa um what my
girl's sister works at Sage well was out
there and she like she texted my girl
hey Felipe is here I'm like [__] that
you're lying I like yeah that F's eating
with his wife and I was like oh man I'm
at work and I'm like I'm hating so I
mean I've been spreading the word about
you like I told my girl we watch a
Netflix special and then she kind of
stopped
dying everybody at work and everybody
just like just vibing with you so it's
really cool know hell yeah s your nickel
Park yeah ni Park yeah she works out
there and it's crazy she seen you there
a couple times I'm like [__] every time
going to during the day something all
it's cool though you know what I mean so
um but you know I'm I'm going to see you
guys up in uh at the B problem in
September so hopefully I can catch you
guys out there and you know take a
picture of you guys yeah no problem
we'll definitely take a picture hell
yeah dog yeah and uh yeah R I follow
both you guys on Snapchat but you know
it's cool that R follow me back so
that's cool man appreciate it oh hell no
I'll follow you back too just leave me a
message I mean it's cool if I can plug
it in if it's cool or not yeah plug it
in yeah dude yeah it's a it's I don't
know if you remember it's a For Real p h
a r w e l yeah yeah yeah for real dude I
was [__] every now and then if I see
something cool I'll leave a little
[__] emoji on there yeah yeah I got
that on Instagram and stuff so you know
same thing but know just much sub to you
phip and uh Another Love question dude I
mean yeah I like my thir question I've
been telling my friend that I told my
friend about the podcast um I I'm a big
fan of you and uh and hey to bring up
his game but he's you know he's a guy
followed through uh Jo cor I heard about
your it The Comedy Store or yeah with
your with your with your wife Lisa so
yeah story dude huh I just want to know
I just want to know the back story why
like you him don't get him I mean don't
like don't you guys are peing or what
not you know what I mean oh it's just
because um I caught that fool hanging
out at Fat Tuesday like the Black Knight
and he was upstairs and he wasn't like
he was just watching every black
comedian perform like really watching
him bro like staring and the whole time
he didn't ask to go up and I saw him do
it two times and I se is this guy here
writing jokes so I just got I say so I
just called him out on it and then later
on I saw him do a um another joke and I
said wait a minute I know that joke and
because this guy's hanging out at the on
on on on black Sunday night and just to
[__] Still Still new and Sons or
whatever he still um premises from these
black Comics cuz why would you go hang
out at a black show and not go up I'm
studying yeah yeah true so he just got
mad I would accuse him of anything he
just got mad one guys like yeah I
[__] listen to Geor CL thing Pandora
and I give him a [__] thumbs down I'm
like what the [__] is going
on [__] m whatever what the hell
going
on
investigator investigator it's hilarious
now I know the b f but that's that's
what up
manell so yeah I mean appreciate you
guys what you're doing you know big ups
and U you know I got a lot I got a lot
of love for you guys so for you rodo
you're shining bro you know I mean
likewise brother thank you for the love
hell yeah man thank you we love you too
bro you can long as you listen you can
listen to anybody bro we still got to
love for you it's all gravy it's between
us and them by the way my name is Eric
from from Fullerton but I'm actually
from LA but you know just much love to
you guys out there fullon bro that's the
place bro where you get drunk college
chicks right there on Commonwealth in
har I to th a show there with that BD
dude he had a show right there on
Fullerton oh oh where it was a bar the
ball dude he was he to day P
Stars oh [__] he to have them far ass G
like in Tustin bobel Bob perel he's the
king of the OC for a
while that's what we had he had a comedy
show right there on ftin and um o what's
the name of the orange yeah cuz the last
time I performed fullon was at the slide
bar oh yeah yeah only popping up there
you see a lot of girls out
there for no reason you know yeah hell
yeah dude yeah I mean I appreciate uh
taking a call guys and uh I'll
definitely see you guys out there in
September show love appreciate [__] yeah
ER keep shining dog all right man take
care man love you
guys what's up
fool
hello hello what's up
fool what's up fool was I happy
dog how you been
dog good just chilling F kicking it
kicking it where bro PMA
you you wish Fool by the Richie Valen
statue
eh no this is Paul calling from norw oh
[__] what's up Paul from Big Norwalk how
you
been good Bo what you doing over they're
hanging up by huh I just had to call in
man and you know show some love but I
got a good question for you yes what up
all right so I know you guys always be
you know throwing down the comedy cheese
man but the cheese man I want to know is
what's up with you and joy
Coy I always hear you talk about him but
I don't know the story oh what happened
was um we just finished telling people
yeah just now this what happened man we
had beef okay we had it wasn't even no
beef okay no beef but
um you know I I call that fo a joke
Thief one time on I made a poster and
and like Conan the Barbarian stabbing a
bunch of Comedians and he was one of the
comedians that was getting stabbed like
Conan the Barbarian and then he got mad
and go what the hell Philippe wants to
kill me and um so one night my
girlfriend which is my wife now she was
working at the Laugh Factory and then
this guy went to go cry to the manager
or the or whoever he cried the LA
Factory and he told pretty much a [__]
bro he told the the the manager I can't
work and do comedy comfortably if this
waitress is here but what he should have
really said I'm afraid of Filipe sparza
and since his wife is working here I
can't beat up Filipe sparza so I'm gonna
try to get his wife fired that way it
could affect Filipe farza so that's the
beef and she ended up getting fired
right yeah she end up getting fired a
that's whack yeah yeah bro inste instead
of being man to man bro the beef between
it's like you and I have a beef I'm not
going to take the beef out on your
girlfriend or your brother or your next
door neighbor our beef is between you
and I if you're if your if your brother
is still friends with me you know like
if you're if my friends are still
friends with you I'm not going to hate
my friends because they're your friends
my beef is between you and me and that's
something that that piece of [__]
couldn't
understand hey but how can a Vegan have
beef oh was a good one bro but I'm bu it
was it was vegan beef bro it was it was
not it was um it was um yeah it was
Tempe we'll be here all week you know
yeah man it was gluten this dog I had to
slide it in there dog I had to slide it
in what she
said you surprise me you know you got me
with a little Vienna sausage just a
little
one all right guys I'm not g to take
more of your time but I love the show
and uh thank you bro and get through
hell yeah keep shining
fool guys get some more callers in I
thought we explained it the last podcast
I know I guess he had it on mute I think
let get fast forward
it what's up
fool hello yo who's this Joe Koy
no hell hello who's this this is Josh
what's up fol what's happening Josh
what's up f
how you been bro how's the sunset
room what's up it feels good man I can't
complain hell
yeah D tripping out I didn't think I get
through you got through bro R waiting
for you to ask him a question about his
hat you're here
dog how you guys been man everything
cool hell yeah fol we got back from New
York bro yesterday and we waited two
hours for our baggage didn't they [__]
him up with the flights from Boston or
some other [__] it got crazy bro we got
we got home around 2:30 we waited an
hour and a half for our plane and then
it was too late to drive home so we had
to go drive to enino and pick up little
miklo from Sumer school and now we're
five deep luggage my mom Rodrigo miklo
and my wife in the [__] car hey that
ain't nothing for Mexicans my boy we
know how to car yeah bro we have room
for one more
hey man let me know let me know is it
420 friendly oh no a hot box hey man I'm
looking forward hopefully to seeing you
guys in the Hermosa August 10 that's my
birthday happy birthday I normally go to
the ice house to see you guys this one
I'm going to go to the
beach well we'll see you at Hermosa
Beach bro hopefully we'll see you during
the day cuz we'll be walking around oh
yeah oh man hey well [__] you could roll
through man we got a clothing store out
here we could bless you guys with some
stuff what's the name of the clothing
Lan uh the wood class the wood
class yes sir and all your all your
clothing are are Engle Wood related or
did you have your own style a penals or
what it's it's everything man it's a Los
Angeles clothing brand but we're based
out of englwood so you know we we we
rock a little bit of everything wood
class baby check them out if you guys
live in Inglewood you want to show Pride
for Inglewood go to this guy stores
Inglewood wood class they got the I had
sorry phip go ahead my boy no go ahead
man I was just thinking about that
liquor store on on CR showw on CR on
what cuz I'm off CR on Imperial I'm
talking about that that liquor store
with a green building the Green Building
the Green Building it's probably gone
it's I think it's called liquor store in
crw yeah I think it's G cuz right I had
a question Bo I went to dinner one time
right yeah hold on one second it's all
good had a get some of that motivation
going
this all right so I had dinner one time
with some guy named Richard maybe you
know him he's a
comedian Richard Richard barar no
Richard v v or something yeah what's up
yeah you guys good friends no all right
so I'm sitting there right you know I'm
rocking my what's up full podcast
sweater up and uh he's like oh man you
listening to that guy said yeah man I
hear his podcast I see him as much as I
can at the ice house like you know I'm
I'm a legit fan he's like oh you know
I'll tell you something that he'll
probably uh never admit to I was like I
don't think so I said I don't think so
you want to hear it all right all right
so he said back then when you first used
to start in the game or whatever that
you used to put like tissue or some [__]
in your mouth so you would to slur CU I
guess I was slurring and he was like uh
he was like oh man you should put the
tissue too I was like no I'm all right
my boy and that's he was like FIP used
to do it too or they would make you do
it or some [__] like that I was kind of
like that [__] that F's full of [__]
let me tell you and any of that
information is [__] secondhand
[__] dude any [__] truth to that
is [__] [__] that dude [__]
started a couple years after I did and
that dude's a [__] thief he steals
material that dude's [__] unoriginal
he steals [__] material in Mexico he
goes to guys like you with clothing
companies and businesses and tries to
[__] start [__] up and [__] get
[__] and going you know what dude I'm
off for anybody trying to make it but
[__] have some [__] ethics dude
have some [__] have a [__]
backbone he's a [__] slime ball dude
that dude and I'm not saying anything to
slander him it's all [__] truth
there's no defination whatso [__]
ever dude I know [__] dudes that AR
aren't as scandalous as he are they say
he's [__] scandalous that's all I got
to say dude and that's why he's trying
to defame Felipe dude just cuz [__]
over some little [__] but you know
what dude he has no [__] backbone
dude ethically morally or even [__]
artistically I'll ask that he came off
like a
douche see that story he's telling you
is um he is secondhand because I know
who told him that Willie Barcena told
him that and um Willie Barcena had told
me hey bro you want to talk right you
should put a lot of paper in your mouth
so you could practice enunciating which
is which is what you really do bro if
you have a if you if you look up acting
classes or or voice articulation that's
what Brando did in The Godfather right
what Marlin Brando did he put a bunch
but see you put the you put the the the
the paper in your mouth and you practice
in your house you don't walk around with
paper on stage that's ridiculous and the
other thing is dude it's a secondhand
story if it's not told to him why the
[__] is he even saying anything but
that's what I'm talking about dude but
you know it's but I'll tell you right
now bro when I was a little kid I had a
[__] stuttering problem I [__]
talk like a [__] machine
and um my dad would tell me to talk
right and you know what bro I ended up
going to speech spee class in my class
and then I ended up reading in class and
then one last com standing so I'm pretty
sure T talk okay right but then other
thing too you had you had a manager too
that was trying to get you to take voice
lesson but then [__] Joe Diaz was why
the [__] you taking voice lessons bro
that's how he speaks that's his [__]
P that's what makes Felipe sponsor
Felipe [__] sponsor and tell that
[__] to suck my dick and eat my
[__] yeah so Willie Barca told me
that um bro you should talk you should
put cotton balls in your mouth and so
you could talk normal like normal people
and then my manager said you should go
to she took me to this class so I could
take um voice classes to get rid of my
accent but then I thought about it this
is what makes me you know all the
[__] [__] up acent what makes him
yeah dude and those are [__] dude
that's [__] going after the money and
stand up ain't about no [__] passion
no [__] [__] like that but anyway
other than that we at the end of the day
I looked at it like this figured you're
way more established than he is and
you've gone a lot farther than he
probably would I'll tell you that now
cuz at the end of the night the bill
came out to like 600 and I I didn't see
him putting out his pockets you know
what I'm saying damn and that's what I'm
talking about dude that's what I'm you
know and I wear that [__] prob my boy I
got love for both of you guys like I
said I always see you guys every time at
the ice house I took a few pictures with
you I mean you won't remember me but I
mean on the 10th if I'm able to make it
you you'll remember this
conversation for some reason we're in
that neighborhood if we go there a
little early we'll [__] try to stop
by dog I will stop by and take photo
with you [__] yeah dude no problem check
them out man wood class wood class
clothing onw and thank you very much uh
Josh for that Vital Information thank
you J you're I was like no I don't I
didn't even care man you guys are funny
as [__] manv you guys are in the
position you guys are in due to who you
guys are and what you guys done from
from point A to where you guys are at
now I know it's not Point Z yet either
for you guys yeah man yeah man so much
love keep smoking dabbing and I'll keep
growing that's what's up F hell yeah all
right fell all right stay
strong at fools just fall the story they
hear of yeah it's like dude he [__]
see what that [__] [__] [__] him
dog over there [__] kissing my ass
over there at the [__] uh Yard House
the other night suuck my dick what's up
with that [__] what's up
fool with C to his
mouth what's up
Rodrigo who's this there's AI dog from
the City of Bell what's up AI from City
of Bell holding it down over there with
those corrupt cops holding it down over
there in
Downey it's right next to Downey brother
where the Cubans took over the city
without putting a gun on
nobody right here off the 710 freeway oh
[__] you're by
tutos yeah what's up dog I'm just
calling and say what's up listen to your
podcast all the time you guys holding it
down and you too Rodrigo you know doing
it good too brother hell yeah thank you
dog yeah man call me say what's up dude
and you know I wanted to hook you guys
up I got a clothing brand called daily
French do la hopefully I can see you
guys soon somewhere and hook you guys up
with some gear dog all right
yeah man totally man rrio love to rock
that
[__] whatever you too hell yeah you you
got beanies got you too doggy you got
beanies I got hats I got hoodies I got
leggings for for girls that are that
want to get in shape and everything we
got everything unlocked do he got the
Maga
fantas we got we got it on Ro we got
everything if you want to check it out
daily
fresh. say it again so the listener can
know Daily fresh. La we got an Instagram
you can follow us on that and now you
can just go on the website and check it
out dude we got here at L gear and um
just calling in saying what's up I
always listen to your podcast every day
dude at work guys make my day go by
thank you daily fresh daily fresh La bro
daily fresh
refresh. sound like Kush hell yeah dude
and what's up with your little got that
[__] unlocked
too and what's up what's up with your
little city government they fix all that
[__] with the cops and the [__] city
council and the mayor oh these dud just
got on on to some [__] brother know he
got into some [__] and the city still
corrupt there's still [__] going on they
just killed some dude this past weekend
right here and it's it's crazy out here
bro but it it's cunny man if like if the
person get killed if he's not black
it'll make the news huh hell no it was
actually a black dude brother damn may
he was Puerto
Rican give me the benefit of that he got
shot nasty
style well I heard I heard the cop shot
him actually dude but I don't know what
went on right there you know probably
that dude was looking for some trouble
and didn't didn't want to follow
directions you know follow
directions what's up Rodrigo what's up
dog how's it going brother good dog just
[__] chilling you know me [__]
shining dog he's shining bro like a
nickel like a nickel bag just call in
there Felipe show you guys love you guys
are cool cats and you know keep it keep
it up and um you know I'm always
listening brother whenever you guys are
in town I would like to know you know so
I can go to one of your shows and August
10 some gear bro August 10 Hermosa Beach
I'm not gonna be here that weekend I'm
off to Vegas bro that's a Wednesday but
um but soon bro I'm I'll keep it I'll
keep it up following you guys on the
podcast and okay I'll send you guys some
gear bro I'll go out there show you guys
love and smoke you out too if you guys
where you guys back too right on dude
and I'll [__] check your uh page on
Instagram follow you thank you yeah d.la
brother and stay up keep doing your
thing guys and you know don't look back
just keep going forward forward let me
CH on
I look out on this stay have a good one
brother damn what's up fool the [__] we
hear on the street sh we hear on the
street the word on the streets right
here the word on the street is Felipe
used to put on paper in his mouth and
talk dude and you know what piss I take
first of all I how why would I keep the
paper in my mouth and keep talking
that's something you do to practice
talking take it out yeah it's a it's a
practice tool for people who stutter
yeah my the whole [__] issue I have
is why the [__] are you over there
trying to tell stories you second hand I
heard Albert has three kids who gives F
that's like this guy bro I'll bring this
[__] up this guy bro my brother has
you know he has a bunch of kids my
brother has a a daughter has three
daughters yeah he has three daughters
from one girl he has a son from another
girl and he has a son he don't see right
so the the the mama of the three kids
she's a cool lady you know we're very
good friends you know I I treat her like
a sister from another mother you know
she I got love for her she's a mother of
my brother's kids you know how can I not
like her you know she can't do wrong she
cu no matter what my brother does to
this lady I'm always going to like her
because she holds the three daughters
that belong to my brother so got to be
nice but um she had a a cousin who's my
age and this piece of [__] bro he not a
piece of [__] he's just wrong he lived
in the back of the projects in the back
of the projects there was nobody there
like there was
nobody put it this way he never hung out
with the [__] in the who lived in the
project he stood in a back hiding from
everybody watching you guys with
binocular yeah so now he's like this big
shot at TSA at LAX he's like a
supervisor of all the TSA and this fool
walks up to me bro at the airport I
thought he going to walk up to me and
let me get in the front of the line not
even that dog n he walks out to me hey
Albert has another kid huh how much is
that now [__] you know [__]
why you asking me that at the [__]
airport at [__] 5: in the morning do
your [__] job [__] open up
another [__] line here at the airport
[__] what the [__] you [__]
with me for bro you're at [__] work
you have a federal job do it yeah what
the [__] that's same thing bro it's like
people they it's like they want to be
they want to be a part of your life but
not really cuz all they have with a bad
memory of you like somebody going to
walk up to somebody hey Rodrigo I heard
that Rodrigo he [__] didn't show up
for the
DAT yeah dude people are [__] haters
dog you could have stand that for wear a
big ass sweatshirt what fo podcast [__]
no dog weing this [__] [__]
dog damn what's up
fool hey hey
Mando hey this is H here from India
what's up here from Indio what's up fool
what's up fo in hot ass Indio hey what's
up dog you sounded like Mando C right
now hey what's up
guys stop [__] stop just laughing
it's [__] hat over here
how's life bro how's everything out
there it's good man it's good hot hell
no you got AC on [__] or
what AC you know bro I like India bro I
I've always had a good time there yeah
dog yeah I want to hear some IND
stor stories about Bry and colico and
all these I want to hear some Indio
stories fool I tell you a India story
bro I was in [__] India I I think
rrio with me we did a show and we went
to we went to the liquor store we went
to 7-Eleven on that ghetto ass highway I
don't know the name of the highway
[__]
the the what desert highway yeah Highway
111 the 7-Eleven there bro and have have
you ever seen
ET yeah yeah remember all those kids
that were chasing with ET on those
bicycles well okay okay well I saw the
same kids at at [__] at that [__]
7eleven bro but they're now in their
50s Mexican yeah bro I have never SE
like I'm always scared when I'm at a
7-Eleven and I see like a guy who's over
40 years old riding a
huffy
oh hey Rod I don't know if you remember
me I sent you that snap from cancuna
coule yeah fool and I [__] uh I hit
you back dude I was like God damn I've
never been there I heard is [__]
beautiful I have a family member in
Cancun really I heard is [__]
gorgeous out there I have a name I was
the rest of your trip dog it was good
man a lot of moros over there
everybody's dark oh yeah dude from
Nigeria no that's a part of like there
aapco dog a lot of [__] um that's
where there was a concentration of uh of
not leftover black slaves ex black
slaves so they started little enclaves
and then they spread with the people
there too that's what so you saw black
Mexicans brown brown Mexican like me oh
yeah like spell that home though Morenos
that's right see Rodrigo's always
dropping that history knowledge I love
it yeah
man hey I sent you that snap too Philipe
but you gotta add me though it still
says pending over there I've been
waiting every day I check every day send
me a message today bro I'll [__] add
you right now I got my phone right here
bro I got my [__] phone right now bro
you're watching right now I got my phone
are you watching okay give me your name
I'm going search it right now I'mma add
you as we speak
rasa call 110 went through what's his
name bro what's your name Jorge guer
J this said Cy gutier gutier gu u i TT i
e r e z no no what T1 t g u t i e oh the
other good CH with the bad breath has
too
this
IES on Snapchat that's right yep I just
saw that I think so I I don't know I got
to check with my name I don't even know
well bro send me a message right now so
I can I will I will hey I just want to
say h thanks for taking the call and and
you guys are the best uh you know I
started listening to Joey's podcast at
first and then uh once I heard Felipe on
there and never went back well actually
I do go back once in a while but all
about what up pool and the Y man now a
[__] lutely that [__] uh Mr
gutiz hell yeah [__] sucker you better
recognize you know over here with t
Rodrigo slanging dick and passing out
bubble [__] who's better than you
thank thanks for taking the car man
thank you bro way you're the
manip I'll add you bro please send me a
message send him a message now
late what's up fool said
pending what's up fool what's up
F what's going onip what's up Rodrigo
I'm a big fan man where you from bro
who's this I'm from ELO East Los oh ELO
East Los you know bro I went to Els
Sereno Junior High School right you did
for one
year one year what' you do drop out yeah
bro they kicked me out I kept missing
the
bus dude I would hey bro I would catch
that bus right there on Fourth and SoDo
to go to R Sereno J high school and bro
sometime I would get there late and I no
no no I wouldn't get there late the bus
driver he Banned Me from the
bus what a d yeah cuz I I threw a I
threw a 2x4 at the bus oh this when we
were leaving we were already cuz my
friend used to always get into fights
with the black girls in there like
always get into a fight like I they
didn't bother me but this fo I don't
know why but he got into a fight with
the black girls and um so he wanted to
fight the brother of the black
but he was a little dude so they were
not going to have it so they pushed that
fool and then that fool got mad and they
kicked him out of the bus and they
kicked me out of the bus for being with
him I kicked my brother Angel out of the
school bus so now we're [__] walking
bro for three days we walked to Al
Serino that's [__] far bro oh from
your pet where God damn where were you
walking from from from how far away
fourth and SoDo bro God damn that is a
walk man walk through haard because of
that walk bro I think I grew extra
toe ank hey up did you know a guy named
Veno
Verano
Beno n man I mean you know gangs around
here Banos are a diamond dozen bro I
mean I don't know them but I'm sure I've
heard of them you know you're right
about that bro that's not a common name
also go ahead go ahead
bro I had a quick question for you bro
yeah I mean
you know how how is it that you were
able to get a Caucasian wife bro like
give us the formula bro I mean speaking
generally speaking bro
bro they despise us filthy
beers bro don't believe don't believe
don't believe that [__] dog that's all
lie bro because it was a it was a white
woman who taught a black slave how to
how to read and that wasi dougas
Frederick Douglas so um you just got to
be got to got to meet the right one bro
and they're not in Orange County you
just got to go to spots where they you
got to go with a rap bro cuz sometimes
bro cuz see if you're always in East and
always in a place where you're like the
only Latin there all Latinos you can't
really stand out hell no then you go
into a room bro like I walked into the
LA Factory and I'm like the only Mexican
comedian there amongst all the white
Comics bro I stand out bro I'm exotic
I'm like Superman go to Riverside fool
damn I gotta get out of Al Serino
that's chicks around here bro nah you
don't know what they like I know white
chicks that [__] don't like being
with white dudes D I have met I have met
white girls who who like who throw me
the resume before they we go out I met a
white girl once who told me straight up
I never I never dated a white guy I
never dated a black guy or Asian guy all
my boyfriend have been
Mexican and I said all right so there
going to be a crazy cholo after me now
what are you telling Felipe once you go
Brown you'll never turn it
down I'm gonna start that one
broown that too man once you go Brown
you go back to being
black hey once you go Brown you get
pregnant leave with a
frown hey once you go Brown your parents
disown you
bro once you go Brown you have to leave
town once you go Brown you flusher like
a toilet
bro I don't know bro like man I don't
know maybe girls like all women bro like
even black ones bro like I find it weird
that I like it's just the places where
you're at like if you're at a place
where only white girls are at it's going
to be pretty tough because there's a lot
they're used to just seeing a bunch of
white girls but you got to go to a place
bro with v diverse a place like Echo
Park or or a [__] especially now dud
concert go at the pond dog or or go to
my show at the BR improv bro you'll see
a lot of wias there yeah Irvine too do I
mean I know you didn't get your wife by
telling her you used to smoke crack
right I mean come on that's not the way
you got her bro right I
mean is that even is that even true fipe
that you used to smoke K that dog I mean
come on man I mean yeah bro you know
most most crackheads bro I mean you
don't look like a crackhead bro you're
you're [__] most crackheads are
skinny bro I know bro they they used to
cut my crack with
butter I'm a crackhead bro I'll pull my
teeth out for you and show
you this right here is it's not it's not
real bro it's a
prosthetic damn I have no my front te
bro they're all fake bro they were put
in by a dentist for a lot of money don't
a lot of actors tee yeah bro look at all
the actors that that were before they
were active bro they [__] they
all got good
teeth yeah man for sure they got those
like those chicklets teeth you know dumb
chicklets
like inana right there those sixy kids
in Tijuana the Border bro chick teeth
man H yeah damn white I had another
question for you bro man Aiko Tanaka bro
she's a funny she's a funny chick man
what's up with her man uh you going to
have her back on your show or what I'm
sure the future might we might have her
back as a guest host like if Rodrigo
can't make it or you know just throw her
in you know as a as a good good vibe she
was she was a good guest she's [__]
cool she [__] awesome
man she really cool guest she's pretty
funny and and you know it doesn't help
that I mean doesn't it doesn't hurt that
she's pretty hot too man I mean Japanese
chicks generally speaking they're pretty
hot man yeah bro you have you been with
an Asian
woman not yet bro but you got to hook me
up with Aiko Tanaka bro I mean I'm not
good at math either bro I never met her
and already we have something in common
bro you know what I mean follow her on
Instagram follow her on Instagram she's
a very nice woman bro she's looking for
a man yeah she's into religion though
dog she goes to church church chicken oh
she goes to church okay well that's a
plus man I'm looking forward to the next
time she's on your guys this show maning
dating game over here I'll get her back
bro and um hit her up on her Instagram
yeah dude she's cool she one more thing
I wanted to say bro uh I know why I know
why they don't be picking up the trash
in Detroit bro why I know why because
the whole state of Detroit is one big
huge [__] trash can bro damn the basa
just stays there D they don't take it
away that's where it belongs bro you
didn't know
that it's in Flint Michigan bro
Flint the state of
Detroit all right bro we got go go I
love and I love everybody man
yo big fan I can't wait to see you guys
back in La man when are you guys going
to be when when are you going to be back
in in La Felipe August 10 Hermosa
Beach in Heros it's a Wednesday yeah
it's on a Wednesday yeah I can't make it
man what about what's your next your
next show in La man close la like out
the city it'll probably be in in January
at the noia live next year though but
this
year all right man yo I'm looking
forward to it Felipe keep doing what
you're doing man you're fun [__]
Rodrigo you're funny too man thanks for
good good talking to you guys man keep
shining
dog it's co talking to people about the
podcast hell yeah F like they have a lot
of insights this said give us the
formula insights bro like there's no for
there ain't no formula bro like I dude
this is this is what turned me what like
not that I ever was attracted to white
women I was never my thing but it just
what I am attracted to whatever is
attracted to me oh yeah yeah it could be
a Asian woman you you know or a black
woman you know but if she like if she if
a woman has the not not before I was
married if a woman has the confidence to
walk up to me and ask me out or hit me
up hey if you ever want to hang out I'm
down bro you know what I mean she could
be anything long she could be anything
I'm a [__] picky [__] no no
but she to be pretty of
course I'm a shallow ass fool no man I'm
I
I'll hang out bro with them for a while
so they could take me around their
pretty
friends and then I'll be with all their
friends now that never happened but I
want to be like the guy that they like
and then later on bro you know you know
they might be that one time when one of
the friends is
sad and that's when I throw away my
little wit little Captain Sab ho yeah
what happened man you
bombed this fo dog yeah man people like
that Tanaka girl hell yeah dude she's
cool fool was she in porn no dude she
just used to take little pictures you
know what I mean like you know half
naked or something like that nothing
crazy dude maybe the chest or whatever
but um you know just F you know little
advertisements and [__] like that and
little but I mean nothing like [__]
porn porn porn n yes so what's up forx
porn what's happening we done
rare oh we do we'll take
them one more
what's up fo
last
caller yo what's up last caller who's
this what's up F this Fernando from San
Jose Fernando from San Jose I'll be
there August 27th what up Fernando I
know bro I got some tickets man [__]
yeah what's up Fernando you have a
question for Rodrigo
Tores dude I didn't even think I was
going to get on man I was like driving
home from from school and I was like I
wonder if I'll I'll even make it in the
into the call mhm are you are you the
guy that listen to us at school where
you're when you into the
class dude yeah little earbud in the
left ear I heard his
tweet yeah dude I'll be laughing in
class everyone's looking at me hella
awkward fo dog they ask him a question
he goes yeah man I know the
answer that's funny hey man uh are you
guys voting Ro you was Voting I already
voted oh that's it but no no we'll vote
again of course but um yeah what's up
dude not but uh I just I just heard that
like our vote doesn't really matter it's
more like the it's it's a it's a popular
vote but the ones that are going to
elect the president is going to be the
Electoral College yeah that's how it
goes down but I mean the popular vote
doesn't count doesn't elect the
president but your but your vote elects
assembly men Senators uh congressmen
Mayors uh Council people and water
district people and all types of other
judges so yeah it does matter um locally
much more where you live so the electric
college is like are the delegates right
yeah and they're already like see like
there's there's 10 um there's one
delegate right here right for the all an
area yeah an area and this half of this
audience this people voted just say like
75% of the people vote for killary and
um the rest B for Trump right yeah
that's that section now to the Electoral
College does he does he does he um end
up shooting Hillary or he says [__] this
and decides to go for Bush and then [__]
over El Gore no he can vote they have to
vote they have to there has to be a vote
there would there would be no those
votes never get left unoted and but and
I think what's going to happen too that
a lot of people that are in the GOP or
the Republican Party are going to
probably switch over to Hillary side
just because all the stuff that's been
going on lately it's barely starting to
un I think the plan is to let Hillary
win and they come back super [__]
strong in four years hard to get her in
peace too that or just to [__] roll
cuz you know we've had so much
Democratic Rule now it's just like
[__] have like two three four terms
of Republican R what do you think bro
but but what was it well this is how I
see it because they they put all the
candidates pretty much on that ballot
but like yes right uh so people are
split between Hillary and Sanders right
but people aren't split between Donald
Trump and other candidates right but
Sanders is now gone though because the
fact that um Hillary's the Democratic
nominee and Sanders was going to be the
Democrat trying to be the Democratic
nominee the only other ones that are
going to be there are the uh I believe
uh it's uh libertarian or independent
which is Gary Johnson and some other
lady but I don't think they're going to
have that much the other lady is that
woman who's running the green party yeah
there you go so you have those other two
cities but I don't think they're ever
going to have the impact as such as like
Ross perau or Ralph nater
did yeah but that's just my opinion
change yeah because I mean I've seen all
the candidates on on a different ballot
I'm not sure if that that's probably
like the one that we just yeah that was
the the the primaries the ones that we
had in California and that's just to
weed out the ones that are actually
going to be running but to be honest
with you that dude Gary Johnson speaks
some valuable information dog he's get
immigrants are important and all the
stuff that we need to do even like you
know with the recreational marijuana and
taking it off the um that type of LIF
but anyways um yeah um for La yeah a
better answer for you hey when are you
guys gonna be with uh on Joe Rogan's
podast man I don't know man ask Joe
Rogan that long time ago some fool
tweeted to Joe Rogan you need to have uh
cuz somebody made a carmania um U
comment he's all you need to have a real
Mexican on your p uh podcast and they
put it at Ro Joe Rogan and Joe Rogan
responded yeah I would love to have him
on my podcast Felipe is a funny [__]
and that was it but I never happened or
whatever and I think the last time you
were around Joe Rogan right before you
won Last Comic Standing when Joe Diaz
had his room at the bray improv and Joe
Rogan gave you one of those metal pipes
yeah so you know it'll probably happen
eventually I mean dude you know who who
the [__] knows you I mean who knows bro
who knows you
know but yeah so you know to answer that
question so what was
that hello
hello what happened what happened they
pulled the plug on San what's up fool oh
well that was that was Fernando right
from San Jose Fernando for San thank you
for calling dog also man before we go
man don't forget my show dates this
weekend we're at the West Beach Florida
at the Improv August 4 through 7 August
12th we're in Tucson Arizona at TCC
Music Hall August 13 Pueblo C Colorado
at Pueblo Memorial Hall august 19 and 20
Chicago at Joe's Bar these tickets in
Chicago will sell out and they're almost
sold out so they're not going to add
another show and I won't be back to next
year August 26 through 28 San Jose
Improv I'll be filming my 1 hour special
August 20 7 two shows also before we go
we remind you again Frankie Garo who was
a guest on our episode 15 cholos where
are they now will
be he'll be um speaking at the lyola
Marmont University life science building
Auditorium room
120 he's holding a press conference
Thursday August 4th at 11:00 a.m. along
with
the murder victims family the murder
victims family talking about justice so
yeah cuz they never even found the real
ones dog yes they never found the killer
so you want to go meet Frankie Kio our
episode 15 guest go to lyola marry Mount
University life science building
Auditorium room 120
on August 4th at what time at 11:00 a.m.
11:00 a.m. right on what's up fool shout
out right here shout out to the friend
friends that we made over there in New
York they came out to see Felipe and
carolin's Comedy Club um marisola and
Elizabeth from East Harlem in New York
um City Spanish Harlem thank you very
much guys and for the hospitality
introducing us to uh the Dominican
longanisa and tostones and also shout
out to Ruben from West Phoenix shout out
to you you're in New York now and thank
you very much for coming out the show
and keep shining also shout out to um
Lisa Lisa and the coat Jam who was on
who came to my show and checked it out
real real nice lady who hell I funny
when I shook her hand I said Can You
Feel The Beat within my heart Can You
Feel The Love within my soul Can You
Feel The Love within my heart Can You
Feel The Love within my
heart beat what's up with a little
chriso break dancing bro that was
awesome F he didn't want to do it
anymore but he finally did it also to um
another shout out to the lady that came
to my
show laa salera oh yeah she was [__]
awesome she the Japanese lady who came
to the show big fan she sings Sala music
and she's a Japanese woman so Jose
Rivas another Japanese laa
Sal also a big shout out big shout out
to Queen Esther from Harlem she came to
our show and she brought a bombass cake
yeah dude I taste a little corner of it
dude just cuz I was e too much [__]
bread dude but it was [__] delicious
dude it was sweet yeah my mom loved that
[__] it was made it was like a Pongo
kind of it was [__] good dude the
icing was oh man Perfect all homemade
and the way she made it too was like
[__] bomb dude that was nice to her
to show up the next day to bring the
cake [__] yeah dude and shout out to
everybody we met over there from Queens
Long
Island [__] uh Staten Island Staten
Island Manhattan shout out P are working
out night day number
three shout out to Punky what else see
man yeah
man oh
do